[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la pisicine aux victimes s'en aille à
moman a
artiste l'anonymat von d merci
je vais vous partager des choses très
intimes dans mon enfance j'ai pu
expérimenter la misère sociale les
manque d'amour d'argent des violences
familiales verbales et physiques dans ma
chair dans mon sang coule les dégâts de
l'alcoolisme qui emporteront mon père à
l'âge de 52 ans
la schizophrénie
l'addiction à la drogue de mon frère
l'attendait on de mon beau père puis le
suicide de ma mère je suis une
survivante d'abus sexuels j'ai dépassé
le poids du déni familiale de la non
reconnaissance et de la reconstruction
seul toute cette énumération peut
paraître froide vous dénué de sentiments
mais ce n'est pas le cas c'est parce que
j'ai été confronté à toutes ces épreuves
que je me suis mise en quête de réponses
pour trouver le sens de tout cela un peu
comme notre espèce
il a fallu que je mute pour survivre
alors je vais vous raconter comment j'ai
transmis t
merci
tout d'abord j'ai pris conscience que
les violences engendrées dans mon
enfance était une sorte d'héritage que
mes parents avaient eux mêmes vécu et je
me suis dit après avoir vu tous les
dégâts que ça pouvait causer que j'avais
pas envie de transmettre ça à mon
entourage et aussi sur tous ces codes à
mon enfant
le problème à l'époque c'est que j'avais
pas de mode d'emploi alors je me suis
dit je vais créer mes propres règles il
ya deux clés qui mentionnent qu'ils
m'ont beaucoup aidé à réussir ce gros
challenge
d'abord j'ai eu l'immense chance de
rencontrer des personnes extraordinaires
qui m'ont vraiment beaucoup inspiré
leur point commun des personnes très
très humaine des humains des humanistes
avec énormément d'amour à revendre
auprès d'eux j'ai pu m'ouvrir à d'autres
visions et aussi reconsidérer finalement
les valeurs qu'on était en train de
m'enseigner la deuxième clé c'est ma
rencontre avec la musique c'était une
bulle d'oxygène et ça me permettait de
rêver à une belle vie à une autre vie
alors au quotidien en fait il fallait
que je m'entraîne fallait que je trouve
un moyen de m'entraîner pour cultiver
des bonnes ondes et puis aussi pouvoir
évacuer les mauvaises alors je me suis
dit ok je vais transposer les codes de
la musique pour en faire un mode
d'emploi
alors je vais vous poser une question
est ce que vous avez déjà remarqué comme
une chanson une personne ou des
événements peut vous faire d'un seul
coup changer d'humeur
ça c'est le phénomène de résonance et de
dissonances
en fait on est un peu comme des antennes
de radio on réceptionne et puis aussi on
émet des fréquences vibratoire parfois
ça nous fait du bien d'être en résonance
avec des choses qui nous font du bien
des gens des personnes et puis parfois
ça ne dérange
ça c'est le phénomène de dissonances
alors j'ai fait j'ai fait je suis parti
de là en fait j'étais quand j'étais
petit je chantais tout le temps tout le
temps j'étais je chantais en autodidacte
et j'étais tellement passionné donc je
chantais dans tous les styles toutes les
époques
j'avais aucune limite aucun préjugé
j'étais tellement passionné que je
chantais des génériques télé et tout ce
qu'ils passaient les sons les les
artistes populaires du moment
et puis grâce à ça c'est comme ça que
j'ai réussi à dépasser ma timidité et
puis aussi à développer des force de
caractère de gagnante
alors je me suis mise en résonance avec
la détermination d'élite piaf avec la
combativité de diam's et avec la force
affirmé d'aretha franklin
alors à l'époque les toques au parce que
je suis plus tout jeune et ben ça
donnait à peu près ça revienne cette
vigueur
alors pour oublier
s'est mise à danser à tourner au 102
[Musique]
hier comme un coup de pied est trop
jeune fille ma vie dans ma guzheng quand
je parle de ma vie comme un goût
d'écrire chez les jeunes de l'an 2000
comme un gout d'erreur quand je vois le
pot de celui-ci demande passé coup pouce
cassé des vitrines
je suis pas là mais riche qu'une artiste
en devenir moi tu voulais tu me demande
pas si je le bats depuis que le rap et
je l'embarqué je l'embrassé tuer le
match car je l'entends pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si j'avais j'avais ça j'avais ça pour
moi j'avais ma voix et je devenais une
guerrière de la musique à 20 ans je
vivais en chantant je vivais du chant et
mon ego était aux anges puisque j'avais
la reconnaissance des musiciens du
public et un petit arbre cassé une voix
un petit peu fracturé par la vie et
n'hésitez pas à rentrer dedans à
m'épuiser et un cassé la voix sur scène
pour finir un concert et recommencer
encore le monde encore encore et en fait
j'ai passé tout en force
j'existais en fait à travers cette image
et c'est ce que l'on attendait de moi
non en fait c'est ce que je les ai exigé
l'arrêt du versement de moi j'ai j'ai
commencé un long chemin de
déconstruction je me suis rendu compte
que ce ski se jouait sur scène c'était
ni plus ni moins qu'un écho de ma vie
j'ai commencé à apprendre de la
technique vocale mais je faisais pas que
chanter on ne faisait pas qu apprendre
une technique vocale
j'étais en train de construire quelqu'un
d'autre je me suis offert ce dont
j'avais besoin dans ma voix hees a
radicalement changé ma vie la musique
m'a confié l'un de ses secrets si tu
veux être une virtuose de la vie il faut
faire des gammes d'amour leçon numéro un
tu veux de la puissance alors il va
falloir équilibrer avec de la douceur
dans nos un délai aussi à l'engagement
sans faille à m
les vanneaux roux a été nommé c'est
l'aveu même
[Musique]
bon bon
mon
nadal est allé
et à l'est
ll ya là l'état david yala l'élagage et
elle elle est là
[Musique]
c'est là
à l'aller
la merci alors faites attention à ce que
vous mettez dans vos oreilles mais aussi
à ce que vous dites car la voie à ce
pouvoir immense et ça crée un seul mot
peut vous ravagé a jamais où vous est
levée pour toujours
alors revenons à nos chansons
les musiques que vous aimez parle de
vous de ce que vous vivez de ce que vous
avez vécu par exemple si vous cherchez
l'amour et que vous écoutez à longueur
de gêner deux journées
mon ami m'a quitté mais vous trouverez
pas l'amour mais l'abandon le secret
c'est de s'offrir ce dont on a besoin de
s'aligner sur la bonne vibration et
d'investir à la fois son corps son
esprit et son coeur
aujourd'hui je suis convaincu que nous
ne sommes pas là par hasard
par exemple moi pour tenir debout
aujourd'hui devant vous j'ai toujours eu
cette petite voix qui me parlait et qui
me disait tu sais quand tu auras passer
toutes ces épreuves ses souffrances et
que tu auras trouver la solution
eh ben tu pourras y aider les autres et
aujourd'hui eh ben je suis coach vocal
et jade les personnes à trouver leur
voie
par la voix
et ce qui m'anime c'est de transmettre
tous les bouts cadeau qu'on m'a offert
finalement que la vie m'a offerte c'est
l'autonomie personnelle et l'humanité
parce que je crois profondément que
l'humain est fait pour donner
alors imaginez quelle serait votre vie
si vous étiez en permanence connecté à
votre voix inspirante
elle vous murmure à l'oreille tu sais
peu importe d'où tu viens
les épreuves que tu as traversé dans la
vie ce qui compte c'est là où tu veux
aller car la vie est un terrain de jeu
et il ne tient qu'à toi tu inventer des
nouvelles règles du jeu
je fais des ponts entre mes épreuves de
vie et ce qu'elle avait avant à
m'enseigner
[Musique]
ensuite j'ai relier les points
et ça m'a permis de découvrir mon talent
alors ce fil d'ariane je veux le
partager au plus grand nombre afin que
chacun puisse transformer ses
souffrances en beauté trouvé son don et
ceux reliés aux autres afin d'offrir ce
talent à ceux qui en ont besoin
[Musique]
et souvenez vous tout est possible si
l'on est sur le bonne fréquence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]